In the previous video, we
created linear regression
models in R. Using
the summary function,
we were able to see the
coefficients, as well
as some other information.
The output of the coefficient
section of the summary function
is shown here.
The independent variables
are listed on the left.
The estimate column gives the
coefficients for the intercept
and for each of the independent
variables in our model.
The remaining columns
help us determine
if a variable should be
included in the model,
or if its coefficient is
significantly different from 0.
A coefficient of 0
means that the value
of the independent
variable does not
change our prediction for
the dependent variable.
If a coefficient is not
significantly different from 0,
then we should probably remove
the variable from our model
since it's not helping to
predict the dependent variable.
The standard error
gives a measure
of how much the coefficient
is likely to vary
from the estimate value.
The t value is the estimate
divided by the standard error.
It will be negative if
the estimate is negative,
and positive if the
estimate is positive.
The larger the absolute
value of the t statistic,
the more likely the coefficient
is to be significant,
so we want variables with
a large absolute value
in this column.
The last column
gives the probability
that a coefficient
is actually 0.
It will be large if the absolute
value of the t statistic
is small, and it will be small
if the absolute value of the t
statistic is large.
We want variables with
small values in this column.
This is a lot of information,
but the easiest way
in R to determine if a
variable is significant
is to look at the stars
at the end of each row.
Three stars is the highest
level of significance,
and corresponds to a
probability less than 0.001.
The star coding
scheme is explained
at the bottom of the
coefficient output.
Three stars corresponds to
probability values between 0
and 0.001, or the smallest
possible probabilities.
Two stars is also
very significant,
and corresponds to a probability
between 0.001 and 0.01.
One star is also
significant, and corresponds
to a probability
between 0.01 and 0.05.
A period, or dot, means that the
variable is almost significant,
and corresponds to a probability
between 0.05 and 0.1.
When we ask you to list
the significant variables
in the model, we will
usually not include these.
Nothing at the end a row
means that the variable is not
significant in the model.
Age and FrancePopulation
are both
insignificant in our model.
Let's switch to R, and see
if we can improve our model.
In the previous video, we
built a linear regression model
called model3 that used all
of our independent variables
to predict the dependent
variable, Price.
In R console, we can see the
summary output for this model.
By looking at the
coefficient section,
we can see that both
Age and FrancePopulation
are insignificant in our model.
Because of this,
we should consider
removing these variables
from our model.
Let's start by just
removing FrancePopulation,
which we intuitively
don't expect
to be predictive of
wine price anyway.
Let's create a new
model called model4,
which again uses the lm
function to predict price using
the independent variables,
AGST, HarvestRain,
WinterRain, and Age.
Here, we're not using
FrancePopulation.
Our data set, again,
is wine, which
will be the data used
to create our model.
Let's look at the
summary of model4.
We can see that our R-squared
in this model is 0.8286,
and our adjusted
R-squared is 0.79.
If we scroll back up
to our previous model,
our R-squared was 0.8294,
and our adjusted R-squared
was 0.784.
So this model is just as strong,
if not stronger, than before,
because our adjusted
R-squared actually
increased by removing
FrancePopulation.
If we look at each of our
variables and the stars,
we now see that something
a little strange happened.
Before, age was not significant
at all in our model.
But now, the variable
Age has two stars,
meaning that it's very
significant in this new model.
Why did this happen?
This is due to something
called multi-colinearity.
Age and FrancePopulation are
what we call highly correlated.
Let's learn a bit more
about correlation.
Correlation measures the
linear relationship between two
variables, and is a
number between +1 and -1.
The highest a correlation
can be is positivev 1,
which corresponds to a perfect
positive linear relationship
between the two variables.
The smallest a correlation
can be is negative 1,
which corresponds to a perfect
negative linear relationship
between the two variables.
In the middle of
these two extremes
is a correlation of
0, which corresponds
to no linear relationship
between the two variables.
Let's look at some examples.
This plot graphs
WinterRain on the x-axis,
and wine price on the y-axis.
By visually
inspecting this plot,
we can see that it
looks like there's
a slight positive linear
relationship between these two
variables.
It turns out that the
correlation between WinterRain
and wine price is
0.14, which corresponds
to a slightly positive
linear relationship,
as we saw visually.
This plot graphs
HarvestRain on the x-axis,
and AGST on the y-axis.
It's hard to visually see
a positive or negative
linear trend in this data.
It turns out that
the correlation
is equal to negative 0.06,
which is very close to 0,
and corresponds to very
little linear relationship.
This plot shows the
age of wine compared
to the population of France.
It looks like
there's a very strong
negative linear relationship
between these two variables.
It turns out that
the correlation
is equal to -0.99, which
is very close to -1,
the smallest a
correlation can be.
Let's compute some
correlations in R.
We can compute the correlation
between a pair of variables
by using the cor function.
Let's compute the correlation
between WinterRain and price.
We start by typing the
name of the function cor,
then the name of the first
variable-- wine$WinterRain,
followed by a comma, and
then the name of the second
variable.
If we hit Enter, we see
that the correlation here
between WinterRain and
price is 0.1366505.
We can also compute the
correlation between two
different variables-- let's
say Age and FrancePopulation.
Again, we use the function
cor, and then type
the names of the two variables.
If we hit Enter, we see that
the correlation between Age
and FrancePopulation
is about -0.99.
We can also compute
the correlation
between all
variables in our data
set by using the
same function, cor,
and typing the name
of the data set, wine.
Here, our output shows
us a lot of numbers,
and the rows are labeled by
the variable names, as well
as the columns.
To find the correlation
between two variables,
we find one variable
name on the row,
and then go to
the column labeled
by the other variable name.
So for example,
if we want to find
the correlation
between AGST and price,
we can go down to the
row labeled price,
and then through that row
across to the column, labeled
AGST Here, we find that the
correlation is about 0.6595.
So we have confirmed that
the correlation between Age
and FrancePopulation
is very high,
so we do have
multi-colinearity in our model.
Note that multi-colinearity
refers to the situation
where two independent variables
are highly correlated.
A high correlation between
an independent variable
and the dependent variable,
like the correlation
between AGST and
price, is a good thing,
since we're trying to predict
the dependent variable using
the independent variable.
Multi-colinearity only
applies to the case
where two independent
variables are
highly positive or
negatively correlated.
Because of
multi-colinearity, you always
want to remove the insignificant
variables one at a time.
Let's see what would've happened
if we had removed both Age
and FrancePopulation
at the same time.
We'll call this model, model5,
and use the lm function
to predict price using
only AGST, HarvestRain,
and WinterRain.
Again, we'll use
the data set, wine.
If we look at the summary
of our model, model5,
we can see that AGST,
HarvestRain, and WinterRain are
all fairly significant,
but our multiple R-squared
dropped to 0.75.
In our previous model-- model4--
our R-squared was about 0.83.
So if we had removed both
Age and FrancePopulation
at the same time, we would have
lost a significant variable,
Age, and the R-squared of our
model would have been lower.
Why did we keep
FrancePopulation,
and remove Age instead?
Well, we expect Age
to be significant.
Older wines are
typically more expensive.
Since the population
of France steadily
increases with the year,
this captures the same effect
as Age, but is less
interpretable in our model.
Multi-colinearity reminds
us that coefficients
are only interpretable
in the presence
of other variables being used.
High correlations can
even cause coefficients
to have the wrong sign.
We'll see this in
the next lecture.
So we fixed the
multi-colinearity problem
between Age and
FrancePopulation.
Do we have any other
highly correlated
independent variables?
If you look back at
our correlation matrix,
you can see that we don't.
Since all of our other remaining
variables are also significant,
we'll stick with
model4 as our model
for the rest of this lecture.